hello and welcome to zero playing our
thoughts at us can play a fall from a
change want to try chantings should be
five variation you let's castle here if
possible I'd like to get some kind of a
widow pet set up with c3 Bishop c2 it's
the line that recently has been played
by him Carl's and with white against to
par off unfortunately not fortunately
our it did led to him position that down
was very nice fortable off with this
Jody g5 yeah that looks a lot like it
she go in Spanish and at least that
something that I have a vague idea about
well okay he's got 97 in one move so
probably black is somehow a tempo up her
pro very likely
okay we play maybe be three and a four
quite often like players on Sunday in
this kind of position and have no
experience with the room that looks good
however that looks like we move before
he's got a five so that was decent
timing i'm not going to do this then i'd
like to play like be four and then a
four that would be nice without black
playing a five he can go a five now
wherever yeah that's pretty good
actually he should play a five no it
takes okay can do that it's not bad not
sure about this not sure about this and
here's not be 64 but it's not not that
it's not that clear that it helps them
so much so Bishop Bishop e3 note C 4
doesn't help me a lot I would like to
prepare seaforth possible
maybe night over to e3 here not sure
that these positions are notoriously
difficult to play with many many options
so you can easily lose your he lose your
way this is why the closer ulu pass is
such an interesting opening very often
the effort lots of plants and its really
tough to judge in many cases what is the
right way to play maybe I should have
moved the bishop back you could think of
taking it that night looks very pretty
and that Bishop does not but not sure if
the night is helping him that much okay
93 now I was thinking maybe you can take
the two and play a bishop age 6
something like that hmm it's probably
not a bad idea yeah I have to get get
out of that let pin down let's go here
have a look at b5
at least I'm the head of the clock in
this game it's quite quite helpful him
he has played that well the whole bloody
well maybe now take on a five-night over
to before I'm not sure of it and time is
not i mean i don't have infinite time
here also preparing rugae one
that that's funny I didn't even see that
I can't have Luke see one the bishop
there is doing great job night H was
also looking weird
oh and it looks la that looks very ugly
but yeah what else what else did I have
I didn't see it cannot miss the night
amazing it's not really great here this
position let's get it over to e2 and
it's far from ideal but at least there
that protects you three
you can take when you fall away
completely kills me here very bad game
can I go wait wait wait night before
seems possible now maybe the worst is
over actually ah but that's not so bad
tink now that's okay let's let's play
all this position right here
not threatening at the moment to take it
but maybe in the future going to divorce
but annoying and I want to regroup the
bishop okay maybe I can provoke some
stuff here check check taking or h5
think i'm going to take c4 know are you
still totally fine
let's go over to e to check time morning
queen here maybe then he's got King e7
oh it's pretty awkward like a play that
check cannot really can i somehow avoid
the draw I don't think so check check
game draw I don't really see I can't can
be no time with some stupid moves like
the other morons do but position his
position is just a draw I mean cannot do
much and he really had outplayed me here
I felt like here that should be color
okay but he's still pretty or prettier
well organized of course this was a
stupid idea I should just the knowledge
that Roxy hit I did I was actually happy
to be someone's not here here you can
win with I think 94 is one idea or this
is also pretty strong
Wow after that I'm still alive somehow
here I thought maybe i can actually do
something but he still defended this
pretty well yeah yeah the check was was
bad I should know I should take with bad
player and this this this actually is a
legitimate blah legitimate legitimate
try digital bit very difficult word try
for an advantage but even he always has
c3 and this Bishop is stupid on it won't
be three played that very well who ok
thanks for watching